here's that you know the up in terms of
analogies Christians use this a lot I'm
gonna get I'm gonna do it to you
you'll get alright I'll do it to you
Dave okay so let's suppose you lived in
a house this is what Christian a
Christian has I've actually done this
analogy for me okay you live in a house
right and you have a son okay you're a
single father okay and in the backyard
of your house there's a train track okay
okay
and in your back yard is also a lever to
switch tracks so I could divert the
train to another ackley okay so one
night with you you're what good thank
you
so one night three in the morning you
hear your kid um you know his his foot
is stuck in the tracks yes you run out
there you have to make a split decision
decision switch the track you kill five
thousand people or if you don't have to
try out the track you kills your son
what would you do I would just cut my
son's leg off can't do that should see
there's no option see in this that's
what I would do to I would do that I
would make it up to him
right sickest new Air Jordans no now
these shoes are can we cost me a Harmon
[ __ ] hard all right party [ __ ] hard
alright okay I mean I think I think I I
don't know if I could live with either
decision so I might as well save my son
and then by myself right but Christians
go but God didn't switch the trucks I
mean let me let me know let me tell you
the thing about Christianity and God and
why do bad things happen and bla bla bla
got it's in the [ __ ] Bible we have
free will boom that's the reason that's
the reason yeah reasonably have pain and
and an anxiety and stress and sadness is
to have some sort of baseline contrast
so we can learn to experience joy let me
teach you this right now
David Evaro
well the the the source of all suffering
you know emotional suffering is self
centric thinking mm-hmm so you can blame
it all on God but the fact of the matter
is he gave you free will to make the
choice on the switch so you can't run to
the I need a decision out of you now in
light of this new information God gave
you free well yeah I think I'd have to
save my son yeah I know right yeah
because I'm quite certain that my son
would go on to do much greater things
than any of those 5,000 B yeah I can't
comprehend loving someone that much and
then watching them having the option to
save them and not saving them well I
mean look at your sister I cannot
comprehend not saving her exact what
happened nothing no I'm just saying that
if it was her sister she would not she
would switch the tracks my brother Steve
I would switch the tracks that's I love
my brother so much there's no wagon
however I do think she would really
really hate me for the rest of my life
if she knew 5,000 people second though
you have a spoke sec she would have been
like why did you do a kalila it was the
wrong decision I think she would kill
herself
knowing that me down Bob this great
podcast enjoyable go home and write my
note and all that stuff well no I'm open
with Dave because I honor because we
know off the my comedic level see as a
comedian you can get away with anything
on a comedic level I can get away with
anything but not on the mic right that's
a [ __ ] up paradox that happens in
entertainment yeah you guys could you
guys can get away with murder
yeah I say it and it's like you know I
don't know I think you're similar to a
comedian though because you're a higher
figure I'll tell you why because you've
always been I mean I've met you through
two ways I can't talk about with the one
way but the other way first time is
through I did sketch with you at mad
that's right so that's comedy
that's right right I did a Pauly Shore
live event with right yes yeah I did go
to your bachelor party that was yet but
um and you know I ran it you at the
Laugh Factory so it's like to me you're
close to being you have your hot cat
you're a funny guy yeah I have my foot
in that world and I appreciate it and
love it yeah brought so much joy to my
life but if I you know if I have to be a
little bit more careful because you know
I don't have that well he's an artist
he's not a comedian oh wow the fact is
in the elevator I can say whatever I
want the words are not hot yeah yeah but
we were talking about just the different
ways of suicide because there were there
are like suggested sites of like
different ways to do it and what's the
most effective and what's the most
painful yeah apparently what's the most
painful lighting a room on fire with
yourself in it is not recommend jumping
sounds terrible to me to me is to the
drugs because I'm a I'm a drug addict
yeah
you have a recovering drug addict right
so why not do the thing I love doing
that's what I'm saying why that's what
I'm saying what drugs though oh it would
be heroin coke and hookers for as long
as I could go right and then I get done
that and he didn't work but I would that
back when I tried that before it what my
intention wasn't to die why are you
talking with this last time I don't know
I don't know when your times were when
you were trying to kill yourself though
the most recent was last night no the
most recent was like a year ago yeah and
then but back in the days when I was
like who gives a [ __ ] where I'm never
gonna die yeah and I tried that way
nothing was gonna kill me yeah you know
but you seem I'll be honest with you and
this is you know you seem really a
healthy right now yeah I'm doing good
yeah you seem like you're clean you know
you're your present for sure yeah for
sure I feel I just in my 50s I just I
turned 51 and I was like you know what
it's time to like [ __ ] it you know and
just go live out loud and be who you are
and have
and like say yes to [ __ ] that I normally
would say no to yeah I don't mean just
because it's I just I've wasted a lot of
time you know I wasted a lot of time
you've done that stuff so much but I've
been you know some of it's been really
rewarding some of it's been really
miserable you know any you know yeah
yeah I mean you're doing what you love
but yet you're you know by yourself in a
[ __ ] you know the Renaissance in Ohio
right yeah I mean I'm I'm on a show now
and I I'm in my dressing room sometimes
and I get a little depressed really yeah
and I don't know what that's about I
think in my head because for so long I
wanted to be on a sitcom and then and
then once I got it and I I don't like
being like that I want to be grateful
for what I have and I want but I I think
that what you're touching upon is one of
the reasons why there's such an influx
of suicides and drug addiction in the
entertainment business is because a lot
of us are born inherently very insecure
we create and hone a craft that's gonna
provide us with a lot of attention yeah
we set goals for ourselves that once I
make it to this thing then everything's
gonna feel better and you get to that
goal and it doesn't feel better and
you're like [ __ ] now what am I gonna
do yeah you know what I mean so I
couldn't ask you this there yeah let's
suppose arm like um who's one of the
rock stars that died on from STP yeah
Scott Weiland Scott he killed himself
correct I think that was an accident
that was an act yeah who Cornell was
that an accident Cornell was suicide it
was a suicide
someone like Cornell like if he hadn't
been in Soundgarden if he hadn't been an
audio slavi if he was still just kind of
a you know average just a working
musician you think he would have not
done that that it's hard to say because
I don't know anybody's medical history
because there's there's multitudes of
depression and some of them can be
treated with SSRIs some of them can't be
some of them are phobias you know
everybody has a different thing I don't
know you know I know in my case that you
know it had to go to a spiritual like I
had to go to a spiritual route yeah I
mean yeah the only way out for me
yeah it's it's it's strange because I
have that I've had the same
you know we've shared certain games that
are similar and I I - those are the only
instances when I'm really truly happy is
if I'm like out of myself and I'm and
I'm really like actively going out of
the you know and getting out of myself
and helping others and yeah doing what I
need to be doing
I'd be honestly I haven't really been
doing that for a year yeah I've been you
know I've been lost but I think you make
up for it because we hoard rescue
animals still being of service in a lot
of ways that way we kind of can't even
have a moment to think about ourselves
yeah walk six animals here yeah it's a
puppy illegal huh
[Music]